hello I'm Greg Sadler and welcome to
another one of my Sadler's honest book
reviews a series in which I look at
books dealing with philosophy life
leadership organization all sorts of
practical matters and the book that I'm
looking at today is unshakeable freedom
ancient stoic secrets applied to modern
life by Chuck Chopra Connie somebody who
I actually know this one actually bears
in my case an inscription by the author
because he gave it to me at stoic on
where where he was a speaker and I was
one of the workshop providers and it's a
very interesting book I think this is
one that I do in fact recommend to
people who are interested in stoicism
there are a few things that I'll say
about it towards the end where I think
that you've got to be a little bit
careful but on the whole I think that
this is actually a really solid work for
somebody who wants a very bare-bones
approach to applying stoic philosophy
you're not gonna learn an awful lot
about stoic philosophy except for the
parts that that Chuck thinks are
directly actionable but I'm a whole of
very interesting work and I was glad to
read it and to review it
so let's begin by talking about the
style the structure and doing a little
bit of a summary of the work the style
is very conversational if you've read
much sort of inspirational or self-help
or you know how to improve your life or
your business kind of literature then
the format I think will be very familiar
to you very short chapters lots of
examples lots of discussions and then
quite a few techniques or practical
exercises for a person to do he's got
the book structured and it's not a very
long book it's a little over a hundred
and sixty that's about 165 pages total
he's got it structured into five main
sections part one which is very short
choose freedom part to be free which is
starting to get into the nuts and bolts
part three review and explore he's doing
a bit of a deeper dive into discussing
stoicism itself interestingly he's not
giving you a big introduction to that at
the beginning that's coming about
halfway through the book and then part
four is called work out in the stoic Jim
this is published by the stoic gym which
is Chuck Chopra Connie's website and and
business and he's got a very clear goal
in mind which is to try to make stoicism
as simple as possible for people to
apply in their their lives and then give
them ways to practice and then there's a
reference section at the end which may
be useful for some readers one of the
things that I think is really good about
the reference section is that he
provides you with what he calls a
reading plan starts with some very basic
things and then there's an intermediate
level and an on your own kind of level
as well so I think that that's that's
quite good you know this this did come
out several years ago so there are a
number of other new books that that
probably if this is released in the
second edition I think he'll probably
include in those as well so you know
it's structured along that
set of lines each section will have one
or two big ideas being discussed
like I mentioned lots of long
biographical examples and then there's
some some practical you know techniques
and some some other things involved in
it as well so that's that's really all I
think there that needs to be said about
this I think it is set up very well for
the reader who doesn't have a lot of
time on their hands but wants to get
some actionable stuff that they can
start digging into right away
so what are some of the key ideas that
you would find interesting in this work
so it's called unshakeable freedom and I
think that is a really important idea to
start with you know we use this word
freedom and and you know we need to
clarify what we mean for ourselves about
freedom and stoicism does in fact do
that Chuck helps to you know call out
some of the things that the Stoics
thought about freedom and its
relationship with say rationality or
what's in our control and what he's
aiming for is indeed unshakable freedom
freedom that we can't have taken away
from us and I think that's an
interesting thing to Center the entire
book around so there's that
he talks quite a bit about you know the
dichotomy of control and stoicism for
those of you who aren't familiar with
that there are some things under our
control some things that are not under
our control and we need to focus on the
things that are in our control and not
get worked up over the things that are
outside of our control and be able to
tell the difference between them right
so that's important and I really do like
the emphasis on controlling what is in
our control because sometimes people
make the dichotomy and they're like okay
so I kind of let go of this stuff over
here but they forget about the know you
you actually are supposed to do stuff
with what's in your control a lot of
discussion of happiness as being
connected with a rational life a life of
the virtues the four stock virtues being
of course wisdom temperance justice
courage and there is some discussion of
what's in accordance with nature but
like a lot of contemporary stoic authors
Chuck basically follows the line of that
just means living a rational life you
know the discussion about whatever is
not under our control I think is is
quite good and the Stoics use this word
indifference in the plural things that
are indifferent and to describe them so
whatever is not under our total control
is is really in the realm of
indifference now some of these could be
preferred that's the classic terminology
or desire
Boal is the terminology that chuck is
using and he says that those are in our
partial control which i think is a
little bit of a problem with the
dichotomy of control but I do see why
he's saying that he also has some great
discussions about enjoying what is
actually offered to us without getting
ourselves entangled with those things or
encumbered by them and then you know one
of the really strong points about the
book is is the entire set of techniques
that he has in here so the idea is that
if we want to control what is in our
control and and be able to extricate
ourselves from the things that are
outside of our control
at least emotionally or in terms of
cognition you know thinking that things
are the way that they are we need to
apply certain techniques which are going
to change our our mindset and ultimately
lead us to this unshakeable freedom I
would say that is really the core of the
ideas in the book
now what did I particularly like about
the book I'm smiling because I'm
thinking in addition to the fact that I
had the author himself hand me a copy
signed copy which I always liked by the
way little plug if you if you want me to
review your book you send me a copy
right and I'll certainly consider it I
think like I said this for beginners for
somebody who wants to get into stoicism
and doesn't want to be you know reading
the enchiridion or the the meditations
but but plans to do that eventually this
is a great entry point you know it's
written in a very accessible way I think
that this this is probably one of one of
the better contemporary books that's out
there for what it's attempting to do
Chuck is is is extremely clear on the
fact that he thinks he said this you
know in person and in many other places
that stoicism can be made quite simple I
don't actually agree about that I think
that it's better described as sort of a
complex system or a network of different
ideas that that in fact inform each
other but I do see the validity for
Beginners for for doing what he's he's
doing it's got a lot of great actionable
stuff that that you can start doing
almost immediately it's it's very well
structured I would say in the way that
he's put it together there's one part
that I particularly liked I had to mark
it in here because there's there's a lot
of what we can call
let's compare stoicism to everything
else going on out there and and he he
deliberately says stoicism and the
serenity prayer not exactly the same
thing he says and this is on page 33 the
goal of the Stoics was the achievement
of total freedom not conditional freedom
for this reason they did not leave
something outside the dichotomy and ask
God for the wisdom to know the
difference between what they could
change and what they could not Stoics
defined at
so I think that's that's actually a nice
way to frame it there's lots of really
inspiring and and I would say
substantive examples it's one thing when
you give an example and you throw it out
there and you're like this person has
some vague connection with stoicism it's
another thing when you say here's what
they did
here's the parts that may not be stoic
here's the parts that actually are stoic
whether they realized it or not and
here's the payoff for them and and
there's quite a few examples like that
in here so I think that's really quite
good and you know the techniques that
that truck is providing in here are not
you know radically new you wouldn't
expect them to be if they're actually
stoic right but they're they're really
well laid out you know so for each of
the techniques he's got a name that you
can use to remember it when to use it
what to use it for how does it actually
work and so I think that that's quite
quite good some of them you know I am
Not sure I completely agree with like
the Marcus 9 but but all the rest are
quite good and very useful I think so
that is what I like about the work
I think with any work of this sort
that's attempting to be very simple and
very popular there's some things that
are gonna creep in where you know if
you're approaching it is like I am
somebody who who studies stoicism and
teaches about it you're gonna say I'm
not quite sure about that so there's
there's some of these aspects of that in
this book on page 15 for example he says
that philosophers back in the ancient
period were self-help gurus the original
life hackers and he gives you a list you
know Lao Tzu Confucius Buddha as you
know Diogenes Epicurus Epictetus we're
concerned about the human condition and
how to achieve freedom and happiness
that last sentence that's quite true but
they weren't all life hackers that
that's totally you know life hacking is
is is kind of you know doing stoicism or
doing epicureanism light not actually
doing the thing itself and you can say
the same thing about people applying
Confucianism or Buddhism or Taoism so I
think that that's a bit miss a bit of a
mischaracterization there in a little
bit later on there's there's another
point that I wanted to pick up on and
this has to do with with talking about I
mentioned there's a lot of examples
being used and when when truck chopper
county spells out the examples they're
quite good but it's become kind of a
talking point he says you know stoicism
inspired people like Frederick the Great
Benjamin Franklin Theodore Roosevelt
Bill Clinton you know he claims that it
influenced thinkers like John Stuart
Mill I don't I don't I think that the
the connection between these people and
stoicism is so tenuous that we're just
name-dropping basically to try to get
people on board and I don't think that
that's needed then you know on page 34
he says that there's really only three
things under our control
desires attraction or aversion right
judgments for or against which would be
similar to I think what what
traditionally been called the sense
although the judge
is a term that's used and then movements
towards or away and I see what he's
doing there he's actually trying to talk
about the three disciplines that's not
all that that Epictetus thinks is under
our control
Epictetus thinks that the uses of things
that are outside of our control is in
our control
he thinks that plenty of other things
are actually in our control so this is
misleading that that's a problem there I
think then on page 44 you know talking
about the freedom thing there is this
this notion that like you know we're
completely free when it comes to things
that are in our control and Epictetus
and also the other strokes are totally
clear on this point that habit is is
something that is in a certain sense in
our control but it also does hinder us
so when he's saying Stoics point out
that the past cannot hinder you your
past is over no habit is part of what
brings the past into the present so
that's a problem to now notice that in
the book
all of these techniques are bearing upon
the realm of of habit because you do
them over over time I think that in
there's there's a bit of an
inconsistency as well in the discussion
about where was it passion
yeah the passion counter technique the
idea which is kind of a really I
actually like this idea carry a pocket
counter one of those things you can
click and whenever you says whenever you
feel anger coming on click the counter
and then before going to sleep
gently review how many times your
passion got the better of you so this is
not this is just a quibble I think that
it's easy to confuse the passion getting
the better of you with with feeling the
emotion of anger and you want to be able
to distinguish between the two of them
so I think I probably would have would
have mentioned that in there but it's
very easy to you know Monday Morning
Quarterback these sort of things right
there's a chart on page 107 which is
kind of a cool thing but I think it's
actually a bit off in that he says that
in the realm of
what the Stoics viewed as total
indifference he places in there things
like the death of a loved one Stoics did
not view that as a total indifferent
they viewed total indifference as like
the number of hairs on your head that's
something that's totally indifferent
death of a loved one is definitely a dis
preferred indifferent right an accident
is another example so so that's there's
a problem there's a minor problem right
the chart is for the most part right but
there's stuff that that should have been
placed in there and then the history
that he's telling you know about the
development of the stoic school that's a
little problematic in ways that that I
see often coming up
you know people people do this this this
sort of thing when they're there when
they're telling you about how the Stoics
developed he does the same thing that a
lot of people do which is to say
Diogenes is the starter of the the cynic
school scholars disagree
Diogenes Laertes that contributes the
tan ticinese I think that's probably
well attested so you know that that's
kind of kind of an issue I think there's
a few other kind of minor points as well
let me see if I can find this that's
right here we go where did stoicism come
from it's not that the only forerunner
stoicism with cynicism Zeno also studied
with with the Platonic school and with
the Megerian school maybe a little bit
of a quibble when he's talking about the
middle stoah he says that cicero brought
a book reexpress instilling arguments
cicero wrote a number of books
re-expressed oeq arguments so I'm not
sure which single book he's referring to
could be on Duty's could be stoic
paradoxes could be on the fragmentary on
fate could be the tough school and
dissertations could be on ends you see
where I'm going with this that Cicero
was actually writing quite a bit so I
wouldn't rely on the history but it's
only three pages it's very short and if
you
no your stoic history I mean you can you
can easily go to many other resources
for that
so those are my the things that I found
problematic about the book
all right so my final thoughts I give
the book of recommendation I give it a
recommendation for two groups of people
people who want to know a bit about
stoicism and want to be able to apply it
right away I think this is a wonderful
book for that I think that that this
this will help a lot of people this is
sort of a gateway book you want to read
this so that you then will start reading
marcus aurelius or epictetus or Seneca
or or Cicero whoever I think that it is
it good for somebody like me it's always
nice to get reminders and and see how
other people are sort of you know
refiguring things particularly when it
comes to the techniques and so I I'm I'm
kind of happy about about that as well
so I think that this could be a good
book this is nice you know reading
selection for contemporary stoic
conceptions of things definitely fits
into the modern stoic movement so if you
fit into those sort of classes of
readers I would say get this book